I want to jump straight into my talk
because I've a lot to cover this talk is
talk it's really like formed around
graph QL but in reality what I'm gonna
be showing is a combination of graph QL
and front-end technologies so kind of
mainly what I'm using is react but the
ideas can apply to any platform there's
three main ideas I want to drive home
one of those is around API gateway and
graph QL as adds an API gateway so
essentially instead of thinking of graph
QL as a way to just interact with your
data sources instead thinking of graph
QL as a way to interact with any service
or any microt service or any function
anything that's outside of the core of
your application also developer velocity
a lot of the things I'm going to show
today are kind of focused really on
rapid development rapid iteration
prototyping experimenting and
essentially just developer velocity and
developer experience and then finally
the future of graph QL the things that
I'm gonna be showing today I think are
really where we're headed in this
community and if you really have watched
and seen some of the blog posts and
talks that I've done I'm really
interested in the future I'm really
interested in futurism and where things
are going and trying to ride the wave
and kind of be where the next thing is
as its cresting and that way we can
benefit from you know that experience so
welcome to my talk this is curious cases
of graph QL my name is Nader dabit you
can follow me on Twitter and github
medium and dev dot too with dabit 3 i'll
follow you back web and mobile developer
and author and a podcaster my two books
are react native in action and full
stack server lists
full stack server lists from O'Reilly
publications goes along with a lot of
the stuff I'm going to be talking about
today and this is the layout of my talk
so we have an introduction to modern AWS
tech I'm going to build an API in five
minutes an API that includes
authentication authorization database
data connections relationships between
the data and we're gonna test it out all
within five minutes and then demo
overload I have a lot of demos to show
so we're gonna jump right in there I
work for AWS on the client technologies
team and the two technologies that work
the most
closely with or AWS amplify and AWS app
sync AWS app sync is a managed graph QL
service so you could think of this
essentially is something like firebase
but for graph QL and we have a lot of
different features kind of built into it
one of the main ones that people really
enjoy is that we have enterprise
security and authorization baked in
something we really thought about a long
term and then there's amplify amplify is
a couple of things
it's a command-line interface it's a
client library that allows you to
interact with services that you've
created from the command line a toolkit
that allows you to do things like graph
QL code generation and we have framework
specific components for react view react
native angular and ionic and what I'm
going to demo today for this API that
we're gonna build in five minutes is the
graph QL transform library which is an
STL over your graph QL schema that
allows you to add decorators or
directives to your schema and build out
a more complex application than writing
all this manually a lot of the
applications that we write today fall
into the lines of crud list operate list
applications so if you have a to-do app
you might have a base to do type but you
need a way to create read update delete
and list these to do's you also might
need some type of data source to go
along with this base type and you need a
way to connect the operations to the
data source so you need graph QL
resolvers we have directives that can do
things like generate all this for you at
model will generate the database all of
the different resolvers in the schema
for you from a base type auth will let
you configure authorization rolls
directly on your schema connection
allows you to model relationships those
are the three that I'm going to cover
today
so the challenge that I have for myself
is I want to build a conference API for
reactive copy in five minutes that means
we need schema resolvers a database
authorization rules and we want to model
relationships between the data we want
to actually test this out also locally
so we'll get started
here I'm starting off with an amplified
project and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go ahead and add the API
can everyone see that pretty good so to
add an API you can run amplify add and
then API and we can choose between graph
QL and rest
I'll give the API a name or I'll just
take the default I can choose the
authorization type for the API so if you
like to bring auth0 you can choose
something like open ID connect if you
want to use a managed authorization
service or authentication service amazon
cog neither user pulls is what I'm gonna
go with because that's a managed service
that we work with we can then configure
some advanced settings which I'm not
going to do now if we have a graph QL
schema that we can reference I can go
ahead and choose that here but since I
don't I'm gonna go ahead and ask for a
guided schema creation which will
essentially just give us three boiler
plates that we can work with and the boy
the boiler plates that we can start with
or a single object with fields
one-to-many relationships or a schema
that has authorization rules kind of
baked in for us c2 reference but it
doesn't really matter because we're
gonna be starting from scratch so I'm
gonna go ahead and choose yes and we're
gonna go ahead and edit this schema and
what we get started off with is a basic
type of to do and we don't really want
this we want to conference up so I'm
gonna go ahead and delete this and we're
gonna go ahead and start over from
scratch so we want to talk type we want
the talk to have an ID a talk name and
the talk summary speaker bio etc and
then we want to have a way to have
people comment on the talk so we want to
be able to have communication while the
talk is going on people can ask
questions with each other and then maybe
when the talk is over the speaker can
then you know go back and look at the
comments and maybe respond now we need
to model a relationship so what I'm
gonna do here is add a comments field to
the talk and you'll notice that we have
these two directives now on talk at
model we'll scaffold out all of the
resolver all of the resolver code all of
the different other operations we can
then modify those with our own business
logic if we'd like to that connection
will allow us to define a relationship
between two types so I needed to find a
relationship between the talk in the
comment so therefore we have
a comments type on the talk comments
field on the talk and in a talk field on
the comment finally we want to be able
to add some authorization rules because
we don't want everyone to be able to
create a talk
we only want admins to be able to create
a talk therefore we can now use the at
auth directive which will allow us to go
ahead and scaffold out some boilerplate
resolvers that will allow only people
that are signed ads and as an
administrator to be able to create read
or update talks but anyone will be able
to read the talk because we've set query
roles to null so we don't want any roles
on queries finally the comment is very
similar in the sense that we want to
have some authorization rules but our
roles are going to be a little different
here we want to allow anyone to be able
to create a comment but only the owner
of the comet to be able to update or
delete this comment so we're done now
our schema is ready to go we can now
test this out so I'm going to go ahead
and jump back to the command line and
from here we can now mock all of this
locally we don't have to deploy anything
all we need to do is run amplify mock
and this will go ahead and mock our
entire application for us what it's
going to do is introspect our schema and
see that we need two data sources two
databases
I'm just going to go ahead and create
those two tables locally so we have a
talk table in a comments table now
created it's didn't run gonna run graph
QL code generation and we're gonna be
given the graph QL code locally that we
can use to interact and we're gonna run
an HTTP endpoint now on our localhost so
we can go ahead and click this and this
is our graphical Explorer thanks a big
big thanks to Sean Grove of one graph
for helping us inter integrate this nice
UX on the left hand side so what we want
to do now is we want to go ahead and
update our off and we want to make sure
that the user that signed in is just a
regular user because we want to test
that authorization rule so we're gonna
add a new mutation for creating a talk
we'll give a speaker bio
and we'll just do some some basic data
here we want to go ahead and create this
talk and we'll notice that we're
unauthorized to do this because we're
not logged in as an admin so we can go
ahead and update and simulate an admin
user by passing in an admin as the group
and generating a new token and now we'll
be able to create this mutation the next
thing we want to do is take this talk ID
and create a comment on the talk and the
comment that we want to create is going
to be basically you know just someone
that's in the audience creating a
comment on the talk so I can go ahead to
create comments I can pass in the ID of
the of the talk and I can create a
message and then I can go ahead and
actually return not only the message and
the ID but I can return created by
because we're gonna actually read the
user information off of the token and
store that in the database so next I
want to go ahead and sign out and sign
in as a audience attendee and now I'm
signed in as someone else and I want to
go ahead and create this comment on the
talk so we've created our comment on the
talk we've created our talk let's go
ahead and now query for all this so we
can now do the list talks query that
will return our items and you'll now
notice that there is a relationship
between the talks and the comments so we
can drill down and get the comments that
relate to this talk and we can return
those items as well so I'll go ahead and
return the ID the message and who
created it so I'll go ahead and run this
query now we'll see that not only do we
get the information about the talks back
we also get that array nested comments
once we're ready to deploy this and go
back to our command line and then run
amplify push I'm not gonna worry about
that because we don't have time for that
but I just wanted to show that so next
we're gonna go ahead yes thank you
next we're gonna go ahead and do some
demos so the first demo I want to talk
about is real-time SMS and markdown
these are the curious cases of graph QL
if you haven't
is not the name of this what if you get
SMS text message to grab markdown and do
something with it so I've created an app
for that
and it's specially good for this
conference because you can now text
message comments about this talk to me
and by the end of the talk I'll go back
and reference these comments if I have
time and answer any questions I'm
bypassing the native conference speaker
discussion thing right so let's go ahead
and take a look so if you want to
comment you can go ahead and text the
message to +1 9 1 0 2 4 9 6 7 6 5 and
this is going to go ahead and create you
know a new message we're going to go
ahead and view that user interface in
just a second now let's look at how we
built this we well I basically took the
idea of using graph QL mutations and
having a screen that listens for these
new messages coming in and real-time and
displays them on a screen that's what I
wanted to happen so how could I do that
I used a service that you can create
phone numbers with Amazon pinpoint you
could also use something like Twilio
once a message comes in we send the
message to a lambda function the lambda
function creates a graph QL mutation the
client listening to that subscription
will then get that data so I've defined
the data basically like this I needed in
origination number and a message body
the origination number just tells us who
sent the message the message body is the
markdown second I created the graph QL
schema graph QL schema only needs an
origination number a message body and an
ID and then finally the lambda function
looks something like this we take the
message off of the data and we parse it
we then get the origination number and
the message body off of that data and we
create a really raw HTTP request usually
something like Axios
and here I'm passing in the URL the API
key and the information that is the
actual variables for the message and
let's go ahead and demo this and I'm
curious if anyone else is curious enough
to send messages here so let's go ahead
and take a look and if anyone wants to
create a message I'll go back and check
this out but looks like we have one
message
from someone saying hello world that's
pretty cool
if you want to send an image anything
like that go ahead check it out now next
we're gonna go ahead and do another demo
and I think what I need for this demo
let's go ahead and take a look yes I'm
gonna need an audience member as a you
know someone that volunteers so who
wants to volunteer to come up and be
part of this presentation yeah okay come
on so what we're gonna do is graph QL
image recognition we're gonna take an
image run it through a graphical
operation to in a machine learning
service get information about that and
return that in the response for the
graph QL hey come on hey I'm mater
thank you Michael let's give Michael
like a little bit of round of applause
so the the way that this is going to
work is we're going to take an image
it's gonna be a picture from us we're
gonna send it and store it in an image
service that's gonna kick off a new
mutation or actually it's gonna send an
operation to a machine learning service
with the image information that will
give us the data and that's gonna be
returned back in JSON so that's kind of
how that looks we're gonna skip over the
functionality because we want to jump
into this demo and when I come back I'll
kind of walk through how this all works
so come on let's go and take a picture
you can come right here what we're gonna
do is we can either toggle the camera or
we can actually yeah there we go all
right so we've taken the picture now
we're gonna give this a little bit of
Tom this is going to upload the image
it's gonna then you know get the image
information running through the image
recognition service respond in a lambda
function graphed well mutation and we're
gonna get that back here so here's where
you want to check out the info so we
have two people yeah you can go ahead
thank you we have two people one is
estimated at thirty one is estimated at
47
I'm the 30-year old we're both smiling
neither one of us have glasses on we
both have our mouths open that's pretty
interesting
yeah and our emotions are angry and
disgusted and discuss it in
disgusting and confused so yeah I'm not
sure what that's all about but yeah
thanks for the volunteer so let's look
at the function that did that we
basically have two types of images that
you can upload one of a person one of
not a person if we send a type of labels
that means we're sending something
that's not a person so when a kind of
image winner recognized like a general
image maybe we want to say oh there's a
TV in this image there's maybe a car if
there's a person we want to then
recognize labels on their faces so we
check to see if the type is labels or
not we set some attributes we create a
new parameter which is basically the URL
of that image we then call the
recognition service which is a machine
learning service and there are a bunch
of them out there this is AWS but you
don't have to use AWS there are others
out there
we call it detect labels or detect faces
passing in that data it returns some
JSON we stringify that send it back and
then we display that on the screen so
that's kind of how that works all right
so the next thing we want to go over is
real-time music collaboration how can we
build a step sequencer that allows
people to collaborate together and
create music so let's see how that's
done first I needed a base project to
start with because I cannot understand
how to build this from scratch I need
somewhere to start with I then make it
cloud enabled so what I found was the
trap Lord 9000 the trap Lord 9000 was
created by Ken wheeler and big shout out
to him for creating this I saw him give
a talk in New York I basically took his
project and then made it cloud enabled
and what happens here is that step
sequencer you have an array of different
values that represents a slice in the
sequence so as we go from 0 0 0 0 0 if
there's a 1 that means the sound gets
played if it's a 0 that means that sound
doesn't get played so all we need to do
is just take this data allow you to
mutate it locally and then send a
mutation up to your graph QL API any of
the
clients listening to this can then take
that new data as it comes through in a
graphical subscription run an update and
then therefore you have people
collaborating so the way I built this
was I created a drum machine type with
an ID a client ID a beats in a name the
thing that might stand out here is we
have a client ID the reason we do that
is because we don't want to listen to
subscriptions changes that we made
ourselves so if we made the change we
discard the data because we've done an
optimistic update if someone else has
made that change then we refresh our own
client application so the demo for this
looks something like this I have a
website that I created for this demo
actually it's called height beats def if
you'd like to play along go for it
I'm gonna create a new drum machine
called reactive and then we're gonna go
ahead and see if we can work on this
together so we have this reactive beat
box I'm gonna now open a new beat box in
another window and what we're gonna do
is once this machine loads we're gonna
go ahead and set some steps here and
we're gonna see that they come through
in real time over here and then I'm
gonna go in here and play the step
sequence here and then over here I can
still make the updates and they'll start
coming through so let's see if we can
create some good beats I'm not like a DJ
or nothing like that but you know I'll
do a little something okay now some
people have started stepping I don't
have to do any more work okay cool so
yeah this can get a little rowdy when
you have a bunch of people doing it but
yeah we have some some beats being made
now and it's all coming through in real
time and I don't have to really do any
more work from here so that's that's
height beats I have two more demos so
let's see if we can get through these
what about graph QL infrastructure is
code if you saw the way that we did that
schema decoration using that graph QL
those directives that create databases
they create schema they do all this
other stuff that graph you all you know
you wouldn't think would do that this
kind of opens the door for many other
things because what if you have a
reproducible back-end that you would
like to create theoretically you could
take a schema decorate that
to be that application back-end and
share it amongst your peers open-source
it whatever people could then use that
to kind of have a base to start with
infrastructures code is something that
isn't really that familiar to most
front-end developers and it isn't to me
either the cool thing about what we work
on and I think what you're gonna see
other people doing as well outside of
AWS is as you create your application
from the command line so you saw us
earlier run amplify in it we're actually
creating graph QL and infrastructure is
code for you in a folder that's called
amplify you can then share that amplify
folder and redeploy your application to
anywhere for anyone and you have kind of
a reap you have a upward a reproducible
version of your back-end that can be
shared among other people so the the
experiment that I had a few months ago
was what if I wanted to create a
conference app that people could reuse
over and over I'll go to a lot of
conferences I've talked to a lot of
organizers one thing that they keep on
doing is they keep creating apps over
and over and over
they cost anywhere between ten to fifty
thousand dollars to build but they all
do the exact same thing I felt like this
was a pretty good candidate for a
reproducible app that we could then take
this idea of full stack server lists and
kind of put it together so what I
created was conference app in a box
conference app in a box is open source
then we have around 30 conferences that
I've personally worked with that I've
used this I've worked through three
independent consultants that have
averaged around $1,000 an hour because
they charge their clients like fifteen
twenty thousand dollars it only takes
them like five to 10 hours to deploy
which is great that's the whole idea
here is being efficient so around half a
million dollars of known value and this
isn't even something I've really tried
to push it's just something out put out
there people have really found it
interesting and it's basically a
conference app that you can build and
get up and running within theme in just
a couple of seconds a couple of not
seconds okay let's let's be real
probably a couple of hours maybe to get
to get where you wouldn't want to be so
to build this I created a schema with a
talk and a comment the exact same
application that we built earlier
and to create this amplify an it added
the API and then push deployed the
backend this is the infrastructure as
code that you're left with it's a
back-end folder that you can then take
in update and then you know deploy again
you can share this with other people or
you can package this up with the
front-end and what you are left with is
the docker version or like you know of
mobile development you know or whatever
you would call it I don't really know
what to call it I call it full stack
server lists it's reproducible
applications that contains both the
front and back-end so what does this app
look like well it looks something like
this this is a app that I put together
in my last talk actually a few hours ago
took about five minutes and what we have
here is like a couple of talks listed
you can go in and drill down and view
talk information you can then create
comments on the talk and I want to demo
the comments portion of this but you can
just create a comment the comments come
through in real time and pretty decent
user interface if you'd like to theme it
we have a theme file that you need to
change maybe seven variables and from
there you're ready to go with a custom
version of this that's conference app in
a box and then my last demo is something
that I released to the public a few
hours ago Jam stack CMS Jam stack CMS is
a full stack content management system
built with serverless technologies it
has Gatsby on the front end it has
several aesthetic on the back end if you
think about WordPress and the reason
that it became so successful and so
popular in my opinion is that it had
everything encompassed into one package
and you didn't have to be an expert web
developer to get a website up and
running you could just go and deploy
this thing you end up with some pretty
sophisticated authentication and
authorization rules you have a database
you have a front-end you have everything
kind of built out for you and then you
can theme it and you got a lot done in a
short amount of time it's how I got into
the web development and I'm sure a lot
of other people as well I think we can
do better now WordPress is still amazing
but we're working with things like
server rendered applications we want to
use graph QL we want to be able to maybe
iterate quit more quick
so the jam sack CMS is my you know take
it that and let's take a look at what
this looks like in in practice
so this is kind of like a deployment of
the jam stack CMS that I have right here
from here you can kind of create pages
in three different ways you can create a
blog post from the admin panel you can
create a webpage from the admin panel or
you can hard code your own components
locally just like you can with any
gatsby site if you want to take a look
and edit an existing post you can just
click Edit if you're logged in as an
admin here you're given the WYSIWYG
editor and you can publish and unpublish
if you're an admin you'll also have
access to this admin panel where you can
publish unpublished existing articles
you can create a new post you can view
all the different images that you have
available to you that you've uploaded
securely or you can create a new web
page drag stuff around and then when
you're ready to go you just save and
publish and then we have the settings
area which is pretty cool because here
you can theme it a little bit let's say
we want to create a reactive theme that
will it create a border we want to
change this up a little bit so maybe we
want to change the title of our site
when we're ready to deploy this because
it's Gatsby the only people seeing this
admin or us the people that are actually
viewing the site or not seeing this
they're seeing this static version of
this so to deploy a new static version
we can just click the deploy button this
kicks off a new build this is triggering
a web hook to either net lafay or
amplify console or whatever other
hosting service you're using and then if
I go to amplify console give it a couple
of seconds I see now that we have a new
build that started running the new bill
was triggered by that web hook that I
just ran
so that is full stack server list that
was my demonstration of that the idea to
deploy these apps is you clone them and
if using AWS you run amplify in it
amplify push and then you're ready to
roll if you'd like to see the code for
all of these applications github.com
slash dabit 3 slash curious cases of
graph QL you can also to go to
github.com slash jam stack CMS and star
jam stack CMS i would really appreciate
that yeah thanks for the unsplash talent
creators jens johnson kareem andhra
christian spies and EDD
on trade and that's it for me thank you
thank you so much Nader Debbie I have
three questions for you here at least so
there is a hyper bath resolver first
implementation over schema first what do
you think about this I think that it
just depends on the person building the
application I really don't think one is
better than the other I think a lot of
people get very opinionated about stuff
when in the end goal is that we just
want to create things we want to build
things we want to actually get things
done if you can get things done in a way
that is like going against the way that
the current person that is really hyping
up something that they created
themselves maybe it's talking about then
I wouldn't listen too much to them I
think that both both ways of doing
things are good I don't really see any
reason that I would not continue with
schema first graph through all
development what happens if you want to
change your data type model any kind of
migration support yes so you can
continually migrate and change your your
schema and as you as you change your
schema you can deploy new versions and
revert back to old versions with
versioning that's built in and last
question for today
can you run both rest and graph QL at
the same time yes absolutely it's built
in